actually ray and i met over the phone oh
they've all heard the story
no we haven't and we need to well ray
was a source for an article i was
writing for the new yorker
i asked him a series of dry questions
about police work and his answers had me
in stitches
there's no one funnier than ray holt
amen find out everything you can about
this jensen
i'll work on my speech how's this for an
opening joke
you know the toughest part about being a
gay black police officer is
the discrimination
i believe that's what you call
observational humor probably
that's great
greetings oh you know the toughest part
about being a gay black police officer
is
the discrimination
why are you upset with me your employees
are the ones putting a damper on the
party they are acting terribly
you're the one who's been acting
terribly tonight you've been cured and
snobby with my guests you've been
needling poor peralta so much you
practically made him a new suit
needled him a new suit even when we're
fighting you're hilarious stop it
stop it ken terrier is intelligent and
inquisitive with a bold personality
a bold personality we know where that's
code for
she's a [ __ ] i tried to suck it up and
go back to work i put on my uniform and
got in my car next thing i knew i was
on a plane to mexico didn't even pack a
bag i bought a bundle of novelty shirts
at a nearby gift shop this one says
what's up beaches
instead of [ __ ] for human reasons but
you hate humor well i'm a joke now so
it suits me okay crapton you ready to
get curb
stomped what at chess we have a weekly
match i'm teaching gina to play
and she in turn is teaching me to trash
talk the hospital called your test
results came back positive
you're a stage five dumb ass you have
come so far
that guy's impossible to read don't even
try that is without question the
funniest story i've ever heard
daddy's daughter anna's getting divorced
i hate to say i told you so but i told
you so
you know we should fix her up with
bernice's
son what's his name the doctor oh vince
and he's not a doctor he's a pharmacist
although that might appeal to ann papa
[Laughter]
you're such a cracker guys i have a
great idea for a prank
before holt comes in i'm gonna put ink
on the podium where he puts his hands i
don't think he'll fall for that i did
how i haven't even opened this yet i
guess it's unrelated captain holt hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man ugh
fine i'll tone it down i'll move his
podium a foot to the left what he'll be
so angry okay five inches
five three three one one all right i'll
move it a half inch
fine it's your funeral oh my god
worst prank ever some stupid hulk's not
even gonna notice
good morning
you guys at the podium
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off i
gotta hand it to you captain
that was some ceremony but it wasn't
difficult i simply
said what i wish had been said when
kevin and i got married
oh well then i never would have heard
your hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing it's my
responsibility to fix this i'm going to
brighten the mood by telling a few jokes
try this one on for size i don't care
for cheese
i'm a curd mugen
well you're too tired for humor good
news is
our evaluation will be done by deputy
chief brandt
we have a good rapport he was once my
captain so he's kind of like our
grand captain that
is amazingly funny oh hey captain
did you get my report on the finley
murder oh yeah i looked it over nice
work
good thanks dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called captain holt dad
he said thanks dad what no i didn't i
said thanks man do you see me as a
father figure peralta
no if anything i see you as a bother
figure cause you're always bothering me
hey show your father some respect i
didn't call him dad
no no no no jacob i take it as a
compliment it's not a big
deal i called vivian mom once and she's
my fiancee
guys jump on that boyle has psychosexual
issues
old news but you calling holt daddy hey
daddy is not on the table here but you
did call him dad duke you shut up you've
done nothing but lie since you got here
all right all right i was lying about
the holdup but the dad thing that
happened
aha he admitted that his alibi was a lie
it was a trap all part of my crazy
devious plan i believe you thank you son
you wanna talk about it later over a
game of catch
you